hey guys dr. Berg here in this video we're
going to talk about the amazing avocado I love
avocados I consume tons of them and they're
great for the ketogenic diet because they're
high in fat very low in carb hardly any sugar
at all but check this out they have double the
potassium two bananas it's 800 milligrams per
cup loaded with vitamin C vitamin K vitamin E
and it even has a pre vitamin A carotenoids which
basically will also turn into retinol which is an
active form of vitamin A so because it's a fat
a vegetarian fat it has the fat-soluble vitamins
okay now magnesium loaded with magnesium tons of
vitamin b5 which is good for the adrenal glands
for recovery for energy for endurance but it's
really good for the cardiovascular system and
even though it has 10 times more Omega 6 versus
Omega 3 it's still anti-inflammatory because let
it normally Omega 6 is anti-inflammatory and
Omega 3 is anti-inflammatory and this is just
kind of reverse it's loaded with something called
phytosterols which is a different type of certain
fats that help with inflammation so it will
help with inflammation arthritis things like
that but what's interesting about the avocado is
it enhances the absorption of the pre vitamin A
even from other foods so if you have carrots or
other types of like spinach or kale it's going
to increase the absorption because it's mostly
fat of those vital pre vitamin A in addition to
that it will help you convert that carotenoid
was just pre vitamin A to retinol which is the
active form of vitamin A so for my understanding
the avocados are the only vegetables that will
enhance the conversion of the pre-and to actual
vitamin A so that way you get to division a good
vision you have good skin a good immune system
things like that so I highly recommend consuming
a lot more avocados in your diet and I'm going to
show you look just a quick little clip of what I
do when I actually cut in kado to maximize the
nutrition okay so now here's the thing most of
the nutrition is a great concentration of
nutrition is right behind this shell the
skin so what we want to do is we want to make
sure that we capture the nutrition so you just
cut it like this and then what you do is you
take the skin and you peel it off like so okay
that's a little secret so then you could
basically now cut this and go ahead and eat
it but we want this part right here and if
you scoop it out it's not as good as doing
this so you want to peel it right under peel
the skin right off so we just take this it's
real simple just peel this right off and then
do it like that all right all right have fun